Te voy a hacer una pregunta y ya sabes cual
es la norma… no vale buscarla en Google,
ni tampoco, recurrir a la Wikipedia.
¿Qué sabes acerca de Armenia?¿Qué conoces
de este remoto país ubicado en plena región
del Cáucaso?
[Ojo, porque Armenia fue el primer país cristiano
de toda la historia, es una potencia en el
ajedrez e, incluso tiene su propio Alfabeto.]
Pero, amigos, si Armenia os resulta un país
desconocido…. esperad un momento porque
dentro él hay… no sé cómo decirlo…
otro país.
La auto-constituida república de Artsaj,
anteriormente conocida Nagorno Karabaj.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Hablamos de una república, atentos, que no
es reconocida por ningún país del mundo,
pero que proclamó su independencia en 1991,
y que tiene su propio gobierno, su propio
parlamento, su constitución e, incluso, sus
propias fuerzas armadas.
Vamos, que salvo un pasaporte con el que poder
viajar por el mundo...lo tienen todo.
Eso sí, a ver no es que los ciudadanos de
esta curiosa república estén aislados...
todos tienen el pasaporte armenio… porque
esta especie de “país” es un estrecho
aliado de Armenia.
Veréis, durante la etapa soviética este
territorio fue un oblast, una provincia autónoma
de la República Socialista Soviética de
Azerbaiyán.
Pero... cuando la Unión Soviética se vino
abajo… su gobierno decidió que prefería
formar parte de Armenia… lo que dio lugar
a una larga guerra de más de 4 años que
dejó a sus espaldas decenas de miles de muertos.
[Por cierto, os habéis dado cuenta de la
cantidad de conflictos que se originan por
un pedazo de tierra.]
Pero… no nos desviemos.
El caso amigos, es que Armenia lo tiene todo,
absolutamente todo, para encandilar a cualquier
adicto a la política… y por supuesto, también,
para que hablemos de este país, aquí, en
VisualPolitik:
Un país dentro de otro, una reciente guerra
en 2016, una enorme diáspora, una revolución
democrática, e incluso, un potencial quebradero
de cabeza para el mismísimo Vladimir Putin…
Atentos.
Sin salida al mar, situado entre grandes montañas
y con algo menos de 3 millones de habitantes,
creo, amigos, que podemos decir que Armenia
es un lugar... remoto.
Si tuviéramos que describir muy brevemente
este país, tal vez podríamos decir que es
algo así como la típica república ex soviética
que siempre, siempre aparece en las películas
de Hollywood…
Eso sí, sin el militar rebelde ni los deseos
de regresar al comunismo…. pero con todos
sus oligarcas y corrupción por todas las
esquinas..
Y es que, amigos, ahora sí, hablando en serio,
este país, tiene muchos problemas.
( Armenia logró su independencia en septiembre
de 1991, y hoy, 27 años después, el desempleo
supera el 20%, una 1 de cada 3 ciudadanos
vive en la pobreza, la deuda pública se ha
multiplicado por 4 en la última década,
las infraestructuras se desmoronan y, además,
tiene un serio problema con la emigración.)
Sí, habéis escuchado bien, con la emigración.
Fijaos,
(Se calcula que en todo el mundo hay unos
12 millones de armenios, pero solo 3 millones
viven en Armenia. Hablamos, por tanto de una
de las mayores diásporas de todo el mundo.
Solo 1 de cada 5 armenios viven en Armenia.)
Y no solo eso, cada año que pasa, de media,
40.000 armenios más abandonan el país…
en muchos casos para no volver.
[Salvo de vacaciones, claro.]
Lo peor de todo es que las cosas no parecen
estar mejorando.
Fijaos, por ejemplo en cómo ha evolucionado
la entrada de inversión extranjera en los
últimos años.
Pero llegados a este punto… puede que te
estés preguntando, ¿por qué diantres las
cosas van tan mal?
Pues, amigos, una explicación de porqué
las cosas no marchan nada, pero que nada bien
es la… corrupción y el enorme poder que
tienen los oligarcas cercanos al poder.
Veréis, durante los últimos 20 años, el
Partido Republicano de Armenia,
un partido teóricamente de centro-derecha
y pro-mercado, pero realmente, un club de
grandes oligarcas,
ha convertido la política de este país en
todo un entramado de intereses y privilegios.
Desde hace 2 décadas , si quieres hacer negocios
en Armenia, afiliarse a este partido es un
paso casi obligatorio… y si eres extranjero,
dejarte caer por allí tampoco está de más.
Sin embargo… esperad un momento, porque
en abril de 2018… los armenios dijeron basta,
y... ¿qué pensais que hicieron? Pues...
ni más ni menos que montar toda una revolución
en la calle.
Atentos.
(LA REVOLUCIÓN)
Tras 10 años desastrosos en el poder y tras
agotar el número máximo de mandatos, el
presidente Serzh Sargsyan… quiso copiar
la estrategia de Putin y ser reelegido como
Primer Ministro...
Para ello, sacó adelante una reforma que
básicamente traspasaba los principales poderes
del Presidente al Primer Ministro..
Por cierto, ¿Qué pensáis? ¿Hablamos de
una buena jugada para mantener el poder o...
simplemente una burla a todos los armenios?
Pues… amigos, la gente de este país lo
tuvo muy, pero que muy claro: el presidente
se estaba riendo de ellos.
Vale que amañaran las elecciones, que utilizaran
el poder a su antojo y que los grandes oligarcas
usarán el gobierno para hacerse de oro…
Pero esto ya era demasiado… tras 10 años
de una gestión peor que mala del presidente
Serzh, era toda una burla.
Y eso, los armenios no lo iban a consentir.
Así que… dicho y hecho.
El día de 13 de abril, Nikol Pashinyan, un
periodista y diputado de la oposición en
el parlamento armenio, se puso al frente de
una movilización de protesta.
(Al principio muy poca gente se sumó a este
movimiento de protesta… pero, en cuestión
de días la cosa cambió, ¡Vaya que sí cambió!.
El 16 de abril, grandes grupos de estudiantes
se unieron a la protesta y 4 días más tarde
el viernes 20 de abril, el movimiento concentraba
ya en, Ereván, la capital del país, a decenas
de miles de personas…)
En ese momento… fue cuando el gobierno,
que hasta ahora se había tomado estas movilizaciones
como un pequeño incordio, comenzó a ponerse
nervioso…
Y ¿qué pensáis que hizo? Pues detener a
los principales cabecillas de estas concentraciones
completamente pacíficas, incluyendo a Nikolas
Pashinyan.
Al mismo tiempo anunció que la policía dispersaría
por la fuerza y sin contemplaciones las concentraciones
de protesta.
Vamos, que parece que el movimiento llegaba
a su fin ¿Verdad?
Pues, amigos, todo lo contrario… fue el
punto de no retorno.
A partir de ese momento más de 200.000 personas
en un país de menos de 3 millones de habitantes
se echaron a la calle en la capital...el país
quedó paralizado: los centros de trabajo,
las escuelas y las universidades cerraron.
Y la policía, ante semejante concentración
de gente… decidió no hacer absolutamente
nada.
Todo esto animó a que cada vez más y más
gente se echará a la calle de una forma completamente
pacífica.
De repente, amigos, la ciudadanía se había
puesto en pie para decir basta. La Revolución
del Terciopelo estaba en marcha.
¿El resultado?
(A las 4 de la tarde del lunes 23 de abril,
apenas 10 días después de que Nikol Pashinyan
pusiera en marcha el movimiento de protesta,
Serzh Sargsyan, anunciaba su dimisión.
Unas semanas más tarde, el propio Pashinyan,
el líder de las protestas, un periodista
que en los últimos años ha sufrido un intento
de atentado y ha sido encarcelado por enfrentarse
al gobierno, ha sido ahora nombrado Primer
Ministro. )
Y es que… amigos, cuando una sociedad se
pone en pie para exigir libertad, democracia
y justicia… resulta muy difícil frenar.
El caso es que, Armenia tiene ahora una oportunidad
para cambiar de rumbo, enfrentarse a los oligarcas
y terminar con la corrupción generalizada
que está consumiendo el país.
(“Quiero asegurar a los que quieren invertir,
crear empleo, que han estado enviando dinero
durante años pero no han pensado nunca en
crear aquí un negocio, que la hora de vuestro
regreso ha llegado. Este proceso debe empezar
inmediatamente”. Nikol Pashinyan, nuevo
Primer Ministro de Armenia.)
Claro que… esperad un momento, porque no
va a ser tan fácil.
Primero porque el Partido Republicano sigue
controlando el Congreso y sus representantes
ya han dicho que ni van a dimitir ni se lo
van a poner fácil al nuevo Primer Ministro.
Y eso no esto… además… de todos los problemas
internos, Armenia tiene otros dos retos de
peso. Uno de ellos, la Rusia de Vladimir Putin.
(RUSIA Y LA AMENAZA AZERÍ)
Moscú tiene un control tan grande sobre la
economía, la defensa y la política exterior
de Armenia, que analistas hablan sin tapujos
de una especie de “ocupación” de facto.
Sin ir más lejos en la ciudad armenia de
Gyumri, el ejército ruso tiene junto a la
frontera turca una importante base militar,
con más de 5000 soldados, aviones Mig-29
y sistemas de misiles antiaéreos S-300.
Pero no solo es una cuestión militar… el
país también depende en gran medida de las
remesas que envían los más de 2 millones
de armenios que viven en Rusia…
Y, además, el gigante ruso es su primer socio
comercial y controla completamente el suministro
energético. Fijaos.
(Lo que ocurre en Armenia es algo antinatural.
Está al lado de Irán, un importante exportador
de gas, pero importa su gas desde Siberia,
como resultado de acuerdos que hacen poco
más que legalizar la ocupación de Armenia.
De hecho, según los términos de dichos acuerdos
Ereban no puede llegar a un acuerdo con Teherán
a menos que Moscú lo acepte”. Ruben Mergrabyan,
editor de 1in.am)
Pues bien… el caso es que hasta ahora, Vladimir
Putin ha tenido muy buenas relaciones con
el gobierno... y ya sabéis todos que a Putin
este tipo de revoluciones… digamos que no
le entusiasman
Así que la advertencia está sobre la mesa:
cuidado con mirar demasiado o prestar atención
a las llamadas seductoras de la Unión Europea
o Estados Unidos.
Pero amigos… aquí no termina todo, existe
otra gran amenaza…
¿Os acordáis de la República de Artsaj?
Pues bien, es una especie de protectorado
de Armenia… de tal forma… que Azerbaiyan
lo considera a todas luces territorio ocupado…
y no tienen reparos en manifestar su intención
de reconquistar este territorio.
(De momento. los enfrentamientos no son extraños
e incluso hace relativamente poco, en 2016,
se produjeron, en este lugar, durante 4 días
duros enfrentamientos… hasta que Putin exigió
el alto el fuego.)
Pero evidentemente… el riesgo existe…
sobre todo porque Azerbaiyán tiene petróleo
y gas… y eso, amigos, supone… dinero.
Para que os hagáis una idea el presupuesto
militar de Azerbaiyán es tan grande como
todo el presupuesto del gobierno de Armenia.
Así que si un día Rusia decidiera lavarse
las manos… Armenia podría tener muchos
problemas…
En fin, así están las cosas. Pero… ahora
turno para ti. ¿Conocías la República de
Artsaj?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Muchísimas gracias
por vuestro apoyo en Patreon, estamos preparando
muchas cositas que pronto empezareis a ver.
Como siempre si te ha gustado el vídeo dadle
a like y no olvideis suscribiros al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.